-Performing "Blessed"
from her new album,
"When Christmas Comes Around",
here is Kelly Clarkson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ It's quiet all around ♪
♪ The only sound
here in the silence ♪
♪ Are the snowflakes
falling down ♪
♪ Just like glitter
on the ground ♪
♪ Another year's come around ♪
♪ Got me thinking back about
the times when I had nothing ♪
♪ But big dreams
filling my head ♪
♪ That were hanging
by a thread ♪
♪ That fueled desire
in my chest ♪
♪ But I'm blessed ♪
♪ Looking in the eyes
of my children ♪
♪ Surrounded by the love
I've been given ♪
♪ Don't wanna take a moment
for granted ♪
♪ Sometimes it's so easy... ♪
♪ To forget, to be grateful
for the life I've been living ♪
♪ I'm learning to have faith
in forgiving ♪
♪ Sometimes I lift my heart
to the Heavens ♪
♪ Just so I remember
that I'm blessed ♪
-♪ Oooh ♪
-♪ Here we are, together
taking time for one another ♪
♪ Underneath
the Christmas tree ♪
♪ Sweeter than a symphony ♪
♪ It means everything to me ♪
♪ Sharing all our stories of
our failures and our glories ♪
♪ Even when our hopes got torn ♪
♪ We made it through the storm ♪
♪ And I couldn't ask for more ♪
♪ But I'm blessed ♪
♪ Looking in the eyes
of my children ♪
♪ Surrounded by the love
I've been given ♪
♪ Don't wanna take a moment
for granted ♪
♪ Sometimes it's so easy... ♪
♪ To forget, to be grateful for
the life I've been living ♪
♪ I'm learning to have faith
in forgiving ♪
♪ Sometimes I lift my heart
to the Heavens ♪
♪ When I'm down and I'm lost,
and I'm tired ♪
♪ When it feels the whole world
is on fire ♪
♪ Close my eyes and imagine
a choir ♪
♪ Even when I feel like a mess ♪
♪ Have to take a good look
inside me, yes ♪
♪ In the hurts where I found
the Holy, I guess ♪
♪ I'll never be perfect,
but I try my best ♪
♪ To remember I'm blessed ♪
♪ Looking in the eyes
of my children ♪
♪ Surrounded by the love
I've been given ♪
♪ Don't wanna take a moment
for granted ♪
♪ Sometimes it's so easy... ♪
♪ To forget to be grateful for
the life I've been living ♪
♪ I'm learning to have faith
in forgiving ♪
♪ Sometimes I lift my heart
to the Heavens ♪
♪ Just so I remember... ♪
♪ That I'm blessed ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]